I mean look at football right just just
you know the British the British
invented it and everyone did it yeah are
you sure about that yes and Cricket as
well I'm pretty sure about that I'm
pretty sure let's get a fact check on
that I'm I'm almost 100 sure which
country invented football or soccer did
you say we've got an international
audience we have to say soccer
right did we make that yeah I feel like
we didn't why I feel like every country
made football what do you mean every
country
every [ __ ] country figured out that
you kick a [ __ ] thing around into a
goal like no you know what I mean like
you can say that oh the UK made it but I
bet they're like Babylonians were
kicking heads into some fun I'm so glad
we have a fact checker
England England is the country that saw
a spherical shaped thing and was like we
should start kicking this around and
turn it into a sport they probably like
legitimized it and made it into like a
yeah did they invent the sport yes did
they invent the concept of kicking
around objects probably not you know
probably like the [ __ ] cavemen were
kick it okay okay cavemen were kicking
beheaded heads around probably at one
point they have multiple sources China
something Italian Italy some say Greece
I feel like every country could have a
claim to you like we're the first guys
who were invented kicking around things
you know well that's like saying like
who invented baseball and who was the
first human to ever get a long object
and hit a [ __ ] spherical thing with
it but there's like there's like there's
um uh what's the word there's a very uh
like Primal not Primal uh primitive
versions of sports where maybe a a place
where the group people played this game
and it was a tradition where they played
it but it was never officially like a
sport or anything but now the real
question is what's the oldest sport
what was the first sport who invented
sports I'm gonna be honest fighting to
the death yeah probably UFC that's
probably the oldest sport fighting to
them
I mean come on let's just be straight
away yeah yeah that's true I mean I mean
was it a sport or was it just an
activity it was just some bands
I mean killing your homies yeah sport
goes really far back I mean you have the
whole uh the Greeks right
and then you have like they would have
the olympiads yeah yeah and trained and
then they they I mean I think that was
the first ever documented people who
just trained for sport not for like War
yeah as far as I remember yeah that's
right I mean I feel like yeah I mean I
feel like a lot of sport was born out of
activities that were probably life or
death activities back in the day yeah
and then when Society evolved to a point
where they don't need to [ __ ] kill
each other they're like but we kind of
still want to like hit each other and
you know and do all this [ __ ] yeah
Builders fun stuff you know I think we
have some facts yes yeah I mean that's
pretty correct the first ball was
wrestling wrestling that makes sense I
mean are you telling me that like the
like it just seems so right for the
Primal brain yeah from from Monkey
Brains like the first thing we want to
do is just start seeing it's like I
don't want to fight but I want to watch
the big two guys I want to watch the two
big guys like that's that sounds good I
mean that's the whole fun like are you
to this day yeah that's still really
popular I mean it's it's you see a fight
and there's just something Primal about
it you know I've made you want to go
yeah yeah yeah kind I mean they're kind
of right like the subreddits of like
[ __ ] people fighting in the street is
like super popular
people love their [ __ ] I mean love it I
mean I don't I don't think it's a
coincidence that you know back I'm back
when I got clubbing or whatever back
when you know Lads coach was a massive
thing it's you'd see so many guys as in
dancing I'll talk about like clubbing
club dancing is one drink away from
finals like basically you see a load of
lads out you know and either they'd try
to get with girls and if they didn't
succeed then add alcohol in that and you
like most of the time you'd see a fight
somewhere in a club you know and I think
that just goes back to what's that
there's just something Primal about that
right yeah that's that's what like the
case is either sex or violence that's
you know well now we have the beta male
generation where nobody wants to fight
each other and we have these docile
brains and we we've been brainwashed by
five these herbivore men
well you're emitting some herbivore
energy around the carnival right now
baby I want that meat
oh my God that's such a better word than
beta I just want to call people we are
we are probably the most of all the
popular podcasts we're probably the most
beta podcast I think we are we never
like Relish in fights or enjoy the
masculinity of men we just kind of just
mean like I've been eating salads every
day I'm definitely this close to being a
[ __ ] herbivore man we've ever had
like an alpha conversation yeah like any
any
what what constitutes us an alpha
conversation Connor in your mind I mean
okay when you play clips of our podcast
besides Joe Rogan jokes like there's a
man who can crack a skull open up in
Ethiopia and he drinks the Flesh of the
the brain stem to claim that he's the
chief of the tribe you know that's like
the conversations they have and I watch
ours and I'm like why is everyone
watching our podcast I don't like orange
juice
high chair talking about boneless
like I I watched that and I'm like why
is anyone watching a podcast we that's
what the real Sigma Mill because there's
a lot of herbivores
hello hello maybe it's because it's like
our podcast isn't trying to be fake yeah
I'll try to be this kind of manly ass
it's like wait listen we're all we're
all baiters I have a wife I don't need
to attract a fellow he was doing a
better woman anymore it's about ensuring
that even when you're an alpha that
you're still an alpha you're not a
you're not like tied down to one beta
woman well also
we don't have a course that we're trying
to sell
the alpha course actually uh now we
would like to announce the herbivore
course
before it's about eating well yeah you
know
I've been eating though uh it's about uh
you know just getting a really good
score on Scrabble and making sure that
like you're you know your brain age is
making sure that your 401k today yeah
honestly make sure you keeping up with
your daily wordals you know yeah make
sure to stay in touch with your parents
have a healthy relationship with them uh
just kind of everything phone your mum
phone your mum when's the last time you
talked to your mum
you don't need a sigma body appeal in in
a world with these Alpha wannabe
podcasts it's nice to have a beta boy
podcast you know being a boy podcast I
remember that's the apartment I prefer I
prefer the time I like Vader boys
maybe it's Sigma that we don't care
about being Alphas so we're the sigma
baby I mean I feel like I feel like you
could turn any mindset into being a
Superman because all you need to do is
uh make a meme and just put like the
Giga Chad cheers next to next to an
image of what whatever like mindset I
want an edit of the Giga chat guy eating
a salad
that's our podcast did you listen to
other podcasts or any of those I don't
have time anymore that's true yeah time
for trash days and I realized uh I I'm
on one I I listen to you guys enough I
don't need to listen to more guys
talking do you have anything for his car
you look like you want to say something
oh okay okay he's just he's just
intently listening I used to I used to
try and listen to other podcasts I used
to try and listen to The Joe Rogan one
when he'd have a really exciting guest
and some of them were fun I wasn't a few
Joe Rogan
yeah we have some guests that I really
were interested in and and you know you
know say what you will he does sometimes
have a good way of getting conversation
to flow in a certain way I mean there's
you know I agree with these opinions
[ __ ] no no no no uh but is he sometimes
a good host I mean there's a reason why
he's I was gonna say there's a reason
why he's as successful as he is it sucks
sometimes that we have to preface like I
don't like his views and it's like I
can't just be like that man's a good
host there's a reason why he's doing
well yeah but there's an automatically
mean that I I agree with everything he
says which I agree with barely anything
no yes no well I don't think there's
anything wrong with listening to you
know another Viewpoint that you might
not necessarily agree with I agree I
agree like I think in fact that helps
you keep a more open mind and have a
healthier mindset because I do it all
the time even like it's weird because
there's been times in like my let's say
internet history where I've got like the
odd comment of just like oh why is
gigock surprise subscribe to this person
we're following this person he must
follow their views or something and I'm
like no like I think sometimes I just
want to see what that guy's saying just
to see how the other side thinks
sometimes or how that view of uh how
that view of that person is like uh like
put out there yeah because I think it's
important to at least know what
everyone's saying otherwise you're just
gonna be stuck in your own little bubble
if anything like a lot of the YouTubers
I like watching like podcast or not are
the ones where I barely ever agree with
what they're actually saying but yeah
the way that they frame that opposite
opinion that they might have to me is so
interesting presented that it just makes
me listen and like at the end of the
video you know I might not agree with it
necessarily but I'm like well you know
it was still a good video because now I
got a better more you know I guess
nuanced opinion yeah of the other side
yes you know yeah as you said like it
opens up like I love watching needle
drop for that reason because like I
barely ever agree with the opinions he
has on music right but it's still
interesting to hear his opinion yeah
it's like oh okay you know I might not
agree with that opinion necessarily but
the way that he phrased that particular
opinion makes me think about all of my
other opinions on other [ __ ] that I
might have because it just opens me up
to a new idea if that makes sense